CREATED A MASSIVE INFORMATIONAL
CRISIS IN THIS COUNTRY.
BY THE WAY, THEY ARE DOING A
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION,
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY SEAN SPICER.
GET ALONG, YOU TRY TO BE NICE.
IT SEEMS NOTHING YOU COULD DO
WHATEVER APPEASE THAT GROUP THAT
WAS IN THAT WHITE HOUSE PRESS
CORPS.
AM I OVERSTATING IT?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO IT ALL.
I THINK THAT A FREE PRESS IS
ESSENTIAL TO A DEMOCRACY.
THE CREDIBILITY AND THE TRUST
THAT THE PRESS HAS.
THE PROBLEM IS IF YOU CAN'T
TRUST ONE STORY OR ONE SOURCE IN
A STORY, ONE OF THESE MILLIONS
OF UNNAMED ANONYMOUS SOURCES,
WHICH STORIES DO YOU BELIEVE?
WHAT SOURCES DO YOU BELIEVE?
I THINK THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
YOU CAN'T SORT OF PICK AND
CHOOSE ONE OF THE OTHER, WHICH
STORIES TO BELIEVE IN WHICH
AND MALICIOUS ATTACKS ON THE
PRESIDENT AND CONSERVATIVE
POLICIES.
BUT THERE'S A BIGGER POINT HERE,
WHICH IS THAT IN THE BRIAN ROSS
STORY, IT MOVED MARKETS.
WHAT BRIAN ROSS DID IN THE CLIP
THAT YOU PLAYED IS SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENS ALL TOO OFTEN.
THEY DON'T CORRECT IT, THEY
DON'T APOLOGIZE FOR IT, THEY
"UPDATED.
AND THAT'S A COPOUT.
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
WHEN SOMEONE ELSE MAKES A
MISTAKE OR ADD SOMETHING TO IT
THEY SAY THAT THEY LIE OR MISLED
THEM.
THEY HOLD EVERYBODY ELSE TO ONE
STANDARD AND THEMSELVES TO QUITE
ANOTHER.
>> Sean: -THINK IT'S BIGGER
BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK OVER THE
AFTER A YEAR HAS BEEN DEBUNKED,
HAS NOT BEEN PROVEN TRUE.
BUT THERE IS A RUSSIA COLLUSION
STORY, THAT HILLARY, NOW WE KNOW
HER RUNNING THE DNC
MICHAEL STEELE, THAT PAID
ISN'T THAT THE SAME AS COLLUDING
TO INFLUENCE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
IN THE MIDDLE OF AN ELECTION
I'VE SEEN THIS WHETHER YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT CAMPAIGNS OR ON
POLICY MATTERS.
THE LEFT-WING LIBERAL NARRATIVE
WINS EVERY TIME.
AS A REAL STORY.
SHE PAID FOR THAT PHONY
SILICEOUS BEGAN PROPAGANDA THAT
GOT SPREAD TO INFLUENCE
AMERICANS.
>> YOU LOOK AT THE RAINY ONE
DEAL.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER OF
SPEECHES THAT BILL CLINTON GAVE
OVER IN RUSSIA AND GOT PAID FOR.
THERE IS A CLEAR AND CONCRETE
>> Sean: 'S THERE'S ALSO
SOMETHING ELSE THAT'S HAPPENING
HERE.
YOU HAVE NOW -- FOR THOSE THAT
FOLLOW THE SHOW, YOU ARE
FAMILIAR WITH IT, AND THAT IS WE
HAVE DISCOVERED THAT ROBERT
MUELLER'S TEAM, THAT JAMES COMEY
FBI THAT WE ALL BECAME KNOWN
ABOUT LAST WEEK.
LITERALLY THEY ARE WRITING HER
EXONERATION WITHOUT DOING THE
COMPLETE INVESTIGATION.
DIDN'T THE MEDIA KIT A LITTLE
SUSPICIOUS ABOUT 33,000 DELETED
EMAILS IN THE BATHROOM OF A
MOM-AND-POP SHOP THAT IT DID
HAVE CLASSIFIED TOP SECRET
SPECIAL ACCESS PROGRAM
INFORMATION ON.
MISHANDLING INFORMATION IS A
FELONY.
DESTROYING THAT INFORMATION IS A
AND THEN JUST FOR GOOD MEASURE
SHE USED BLEACH PIT AND ACID
WASHED THE HARD DRIVES AND
THE FACT THAT THAT EXONERATION,
PETER AND JAMES COMEY WROTE THAT
MEDIA WHO IS DOING JOB.
IT'S WHAT CHOOSE NOT TO COVER
THAT'S ALSO CORRUPT TO ME.
>> YOU ALSO REMEMBER THAT THE
DNC WOULDN'T ALLOW THE FBI TO
EVEN EXAMINE THEIR SERVERS.
NO ONE SEEMED TO HAVE A PROBLEM
HAPPENED LAST CYCLE THAT I THINK
HAS LARGELY BEEN SWEPT UNDER THE
RUG.
AND NONE OF THE KEY QUESTIONS
ARE ACTUALLY BEING ASKED.
I THINK IT'S AMAZING HOW WHEN
YOU HAVE CONCRETE FACTS ON ONE
SIDE THAT SHOULD LEAD PEOPLE TO
WANT TO GET A DEEPER
SALACIOUS, HYPOTHETICAL IDEA IS
WHAT WE SPEND THE TIME FOCUSING
ON.
I THINK OUR PRIORITIES, OR AT
LEAST THE MEDIA'S PRIORITIES ARE
BACKWARDS AND WHERE THE PROBLEMS
ARE.
>> Sean: IT'S NEVER BEEN THIS
BAD.
MY 30TH YEAR IN RADIO, MY 23RD
YEAR HERE AT FOX.
IT HAS NEVER, EVER EVER BEEN
THIS BAD.
IF YOU HAVE SOME BIG
ANNOUNCEMENT, GO AHEAD AND HIT
US WITH IT.
IS IT GOOD OR BAD?
>> IT'S GOOD.
AND I THINK IT'S LARGELY DRIVEN
OFF WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT NOW.
I LOOKED BACK AT THE COVERAGE OF
THIS WHITE HOUSE.
I REALIZED THE STORIES THAT ARE
BEING TOLD ARE NOT AN ACCURATE
REPRESENTATION OF WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WENT THERE TO
GET THE NOMINATION, TO
TRANSITION TO THE WHITE HOUSE
AND THEN HIS FIRST SIX MONTHS IN
OFFICE.
I'M GOING TO WRITE A BOOK THAT
WILL COME OUT IN THE SUMMER OF
2018.
TRACK OF WHEN IT'S GOING TO BE
PUBLISHED AND GET INSIDE
INFORMATION.
BUT I'VE DECIDED THAT IT IS
A REAL UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
HAPPENED THROUGH EACH OF THOSE
CRUCIAL POINTS IN OUR HISTORY.
>> Sean: THIS WAS PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MOST FASCINATING
ELECTIONS EVER.
IN THAT REGARD.
AND ALL OF THE MEDIA THAT NIGHT
THAT HE WON WAS LIKE ONE BIG
FUNERAL.
>> DOES A LOT OF STUFF THAT THE